in the first two parts of the series we
looked at why Chicago so segregated and
how segregation affects its schools in
this part I'll spend a day on Chicago's
South Side with someone who has a
different vision for solving the city's
crime this is 79 it's one of the
deadliest streets in the city
this whole Stephanie night strip the
southside of Chicago has long had a
reputation of violence and poverty this
comes from years of racist policies that
have left this part of the city separate
with little access to resources or
Economic Opportunity and most of the
time the city's answer to this violence
is more police do solemnly swear
but for many who live here like
community organizer Jamal Green adding
more police to the streets is not the
answer
Jamal grew up in the heart of the
Southside in the Auburn Gresham and
Inglewood neighborhoods he made national
news during an MSNBC Town Hall in
February during a conversation about
Chicago's violence you could put a
hundred thousand police officers on the
street that will not reduce violence in
the city of Chicago because police are
only there to react
his name is rahm emanuel and this mayor
that we have in the city of chicago does
not care about black people Jamal is
only 21 years old but his passion is
infectious so when I went home to
Chicago to work on this series I decided
I needed to spend a day seeing the south
side and its potential through his eyes
I was a class clown in school I got
kicked out of nine schools when I went
to about 12 throughout my school life
you know I was a troublemaker but I
didn't take it to the streets I think I
just had so much energy and was seeing
so many things around and my environment
that I didn't like you know that I
wanted to change and I felt like nobody
was actually trying to change things
I used to live right here on Ibaka as we
call it so all the guys were sitting
right here in front of this house and I
was coming down the street and I ended
up crossing the street to go back
towards my house and so once he starts
shooting like that gate that fits wasn't
right there and I had went right behind
that bush as he was shooting all the
people right here and so I was just
watching them shoot I've seen large guns
I've seen drugs I've seen people being
shot you know that's what motivated me
more to be involved in what's going on
you know instead of joining the gang or
instead of ignoring the real problems I
decided to be a you know help the
community get solutions it's mine it's
my clothing line that he got on this
okay
it's a medium large let's mark this in
the me Nvidia
listen medium remember I told you it's a
large I just looked at I needed a medium
for Jamal helping the community change
is about people interactions Hey oh man
so he founded majesty Allstars a
community organization that focuses on
mentoring young people man he got shot
eight times whatever it's a blessed firm
they still yeah that's what I told him
man to be shot eight times be able to
still talk about it I'll talk cuz I see
so many cases every day people get shot
once twice
damn lost too much blood life life a
Chicago
let's get some of this Harold they
haven't talked about real solutions to
change the economic conditions of these
neighborhoods that is what's needed in
these neighborhoods it's not we don't
need martial law we don't need you know
federal intervention you may need
federal dollars to rebuild these
communities I'm Glendon a sweet tan
pickle business
yeah is that a thing oh I'm a different
kind of pickle really we all the
different et and then you put a pickle
in no I mean like the pickle business in
business they got like Mayor Manuel
don't come into these neighborhoods
Donald Trump hasn't coming into came
into these neighborhoods so really I
believe that they don't care and and
that's the real problem that we have
here Jamal has learned a lot about
community organizing from his mentor
father Michael Pfleger fleiger has lived
and worked at st. Sabina the largest
african-american church in Chicago for
the last 40 years and his own mentor was
dr. Martin Luther King jr. you know
we've got to change people so I've got
off from option temperature otherwise
we're just like the system and we always
say the system you got to give young
people opportunities well so do we
in otherwise we're no better than no a
lot of these businesses are not you know
nobody's doing anything Hannibal and I'm
their bacon so what I want to try to do
is try to get people incentives to put
their shops there so we can kind of
develop this neighborhood these
resources aren't available in these
communities because politicians actually
really don't care they kind of favorite
the corporation's they favorite the
neighborhoods that bring in the most
money at the most taxes and some of some
part of me kind of want to say it's a
little racism because how can you see a
two-year-old be killed and not do
anything this is the barbershop we're
gonna go to
right here I started my haircutting when
I was young boy
Ford's barbershop and then so much
violence in his neighborhood and the
police station is right across the
street it was funny because I was like
man they do the same thing a black folk
this anytime I kill a black person it
goes every light where he was convicted
right what they got to do any I'm just
being here thanks is that's that
justified killed young people see I'm
talking you is how can what you think is
right shucking jab generously a lie real
got to do yes sir but it's gonna be
alright
yeah they're like you know these with
people fight for the artistry breeze
yeah me Pacific you know I think a lot
of people kind of count us out as lost
causes or kind of the people that need
help and that's all as they need they
need help they need guidance they need
resources they need funding and once
people get in their mind that the reason
there's so much violence is because of
the economics because of the the funding
and resources I think people will kind
of change their mindset no economic
development everybody out on the corners
you know 79 is that strip you know
that's why I'm it meant a lot to put a
youth center right here
one thing I'm doing is I'm trying to
open up a community center right now
this based on entrepreneurship and
giving kids the tools that they need to
not work for someone else but know how
to work for themselves this is going to
be the Majesty Allstars you Silla 12,500
square feet with a 30-foot ceiling
auditorium 500 seats classrooms you're
gonna you know be training our youth to
get ready to go into jobs resume
training interview training we're also
going to be teaching it adults and youth
about real estate and credit development
this community center is no small thing
nothing like it for miles Jamal raised
enough money to buy the building in
April but is still fundraising to do
renovations
Jay Moll may be young but he's filling a
gap that for so long political leaders
have been neglecting what I love about
you know my neighborhood and all the
Gresham and Inglewood is that even
though so much so many things going on
in these neighborhoods every day when it
comes to violence the people still love
each other people still have a vent you
can still have barbecues people still
try to hang out of just you know kind of
have fun and we're pulling from a small
chain and trying to help people but we
love each other enough to do that now
sitting around sad and depressing giving
up on each other that's the best thing
that we have in these communities so
while we were in Chicago we learned our
housing policies manufactured a deeply
segregated City all of this has a really
big impact on the city's children of
color check out parts 1 & 2 of our
series to learn more